I did Consulting and then I started
doing Venture investing in the impact
world and at that time I thought that I
wanted to be an entrepreneur and I
thought what better school to do this
than at the GSB prior to the GSB I spent
three years in Consulting and then three
years doing Healthcare operations and I
loved what I did but I couldn't help but
feel like something might be missing and
I wasn't feeling like I was having as
big of an impact as I wanted to have
that moment of wanting to go to business
school for me was really being in a room
of men for most of my career I was in a
really male-dominated field and private
Equity venture capital and there was a
female MD who was at the firm she
actually went to the GSB and she was a
really big proponent of her experience
preliminary management or whim has been
a really awesome community and it's
going to be a really close female
friendships the most exciting thing
about the women in management club or
whim is really how expansive the
membership is so we are the largest Club
on the chiquitzi's campus and we're both
for women and allies anyone who really
wants to be a gender mindful leader
coming to the GSB I definitely had
imposter syndrome thinking about whether
I would be worthy or qualified for the
different things that I was trying to
pursue and I've been really empowered by
other members of whim and events that
have been put on my favorite thought has
been the set of friends that I've made
here at the GSB and a group of
girlfriends that I have that cheer me on
every day it's incredibly easy to get
together with members of the whim
Community whether it's joining forces
and planning a small group dinner with a
female faculty member or getting
together in our whim groups and
discussing how we can make them better I
found that this is a community where
we're all trying to make the most out of
business school whether it's socially
professionally or academically and it's
really great to have those shoulders to
lean on but also celebrate along the way
as part of when there are these win
groups so groups of six to eight women
who get together every other week there
there's no specific agenda nothing
really that we're supposed to be talking
about it's really just a chance to
facilitate those connections it's been
one of the highlights of my experience
here at the GSB so far I'm really proud
of our whim Community because it is so
diverse in so many ways
to be a woman and navigate Womanhood the
women who are starting their own
startups women who are pivoting careers
women who are shattering glass ceilings
in their Industries we have people in
our class who are mothers we have people
in our class who are pregnant we have
people in our class who just froze their
eggs when people in our class who don't
want to have kids at all all of those
modes of Womanhood are really applauded
and celebrated my advice to prospective
students would be to spend time being
introspective and thinking about what
their goals are what they're trying to
get out of their next step in their
career whether it be academics or
pursuing another career opportunity as
I've joined more clubs and gone to a lot
of events on campus I've been lucky to
see a lot of my classmates
women in particular in positions of
leadership and it's made those spaces
more accessible just seeing their
representation there
[Music]